Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: Jules Daunay
Et dire qu'elles étaient là
pendant tout ce temps,
absolument partout autour de moi
et que je ne les voyais pas.
Et dire qu'elles étaient là,
avec tous leurs trésors,
leurs ruses et leurs histoires
et que je m'en foutais.
De temps à autre, quand quelqu'un attirait
mon attention sur l'une d'elles,
le vague intérêt que
je lui portais un instant
s'évanouissait au gré du vol d'un insecte,
d'une vibration de mon téléphone.
Quand je regardais
les plantes autour de moi,
c'était comme écouter une chanson
dans une langue inconnue.
Je pouvais être sensible à leur beauté,
leur étrangeté,
mais rapidement,
cela me semblait un peu monotone.
La plupart du temps, une plante,
c'est vert et ça ne bouge pas.
Comme la plupart des gens,
mon attention se portait
plus volontiers sur les animaux.
Quand j'étais enfant,
on me posait mille fois la question :
« quel est ton animal préféré ? »
Mais jamais la question :
« quelle est ta plante préférée ? »
C'est vrai que les animaux
nous ressemblent.
On s'y attache facilement.
On leur prête même
des sentiments humains.
Les plantes, au contraire,
c'est un monde étranger.
Elles représentent plus de 80 %
de la biomasse totale sur Terre.
Et pourtant, la plupart du temps,
nous les voyons comme
le papier peint du paysage,
comme du mobilier urbain.
Agréables, certes, mais pas vraiment
dignes d'attention.
C'est un biais cognitif
qu'on appelle cécité botanique.
On parle aussi de zoocentrisme,
voire de zoo-chauvinisme.
Historiquement, c'est un phénomène qui
a tendance à s'accentuer au fil du temps.
On peut le constater
en observant le déclin vertigineux
de l'enseignement de la botanique.
Pour vous donner une exemple,
en 2009 au Royaume-Uni,
19 étudiants ont effectué
un stage en botanique.
Ils étaient plus d'un millier en zoologie.
Alors, bien évidemment,
ce ne serait pas un problème
si le sujet était anodin.
Attendez, cela va devenir sérieux
mais je n'ai pas envie de vous stresser,
il faut trouver un juste milieu.
Il y a des problèmes,
mais souvenez-vous
de garder le cœur léger,
on va régler tout ça ensemble sereinement.
Donc, je disais,
ce ne serait pas un problème
si le sujet était anodin.
Mais les plantes ont
grand besoin de protection.
Et nous pourrions être
en mesure de la leur fournir
et pas seulement pour tous les services
qu'elles nous rendent au quotidien.
Mais puisqu'on connaît si mal les plantes,
pourquoi voudrait-on les protéger ?
En 2011, aux États-Unis,
les plantes représentaient
57 % des espèces menacées.
Elles n'ont obtenu que 4 % à peine,
des fonds consacrés
à la sauvegarde de la biodiversité.
À ce jour,
les plantes disparaissent 500 fois
plus vite que leur rythme historique.
Depuis 1750,
ce sont près de 600 espèces végétales
qui ont disparu.
C'est deux fois plus que les oiseaux,
les mammifères et les amphibiens réunis.
Et pourtant, qui d'entre nous peut citer
une seule de ces plantes disparues ?
Il y a donc deux tragédies :
celle de perdre les plantes
et celle de perdre
la connaissance des plantes.
Globalement, collectivement,
nous permettons cela.
Pire encore,
notre illettrisme botanique nous conduit
à des comportements à risque.
On achète des plantes à tire-larigot,
sans vraiment les connaître.
La tocade d'une forme,
la séduction d'un bas prix,
il n'en faut pas plus
pour nous convaincre.
À ce jour, en Australie,
les plantes ornementales représentent
65 % des espèces introduites.
Pourquoi je parle
de comportements à risque ?
Voilà la réponse en image.
Voyez-vous sur cette image,
cette plante en forme de grosses touffes.
C'est une de ces plantes ornementales
extrêmement envahissantes.
On comprend bien pourquoi,
elle est tellement débrouillarde
qu'elle arrive à pousser en pleine ville
au milieu de décombres.
Et là, la reconnaissez-vous ?
C'est exactement la même plante qui,
cette fois, a posé ses valises à Hawai.
Une zone géographique
à la biodiversité autrefois foisonnante.
Mais sur cette plaine dégradée maintenant,
on ne voit plus que
cette plante à touffes.
Les autres ne font plus le poids.
C'est aussi comme ça
que la biodiversité recule.
Et bien évidemment,
ce n'est pas la faute
de cette plante à grosses touffes
mais celle du mammifère bipède
et présomptueux qui l'a emmenée ici.
Tous ces exemples montrent bien
le cercle vicieux à l'œuvre.
Moins on en apprend sur les plantes,
moins on s'y intéresse
et plus nos décisions ont de chance
d'avoir des effets négatifs.
Encore une fois,
c'est vraiment comme une langue.
Si je disais au milieu de ma phrase un mot
étranger que vous ne connaissez pas,
vous auriez envie de le comprendre.
En revanche,
Si je vous disais des phrases entières
dans une langue inconnue,
aucun mot ne vous intéresserait
plus qu'un autre.
Il y a juste à trouver
ce point de bascule,
à partir duquel le domaine
semble suffisamment familier
pour qu'on s'y intéresse.
Et ce point de bascule,
il est souvent plus accessible
qu'on ne l'imagine.
Alors, rapprochons-nous en un peu.
Pour commencer,
je voudrais vous présenter une espèce
que vous connaissez peut-être,
appelée communément le gaïac,
même si ce nom est un peu ambigu.
Voyez-vous ses feuilles ?
Ce ne sont pas des feuilles.
Ce sont des tiges très aplaties
qui assurent la photosynthèse
qu'on appelle des phyllodes.
Vous ne verrez jamais
les feuilles d'un gaïac.
À moins qu'il soit tout petit,
alors, ils font deux,
trois petites feuilles.
Puis ils arrêtent,
c'est comme nous avec les dents de lait.
Regardez ses fruits,
ces espèces de grosses boules
qu'on voit dans les branchages.
Ce ne sont pas des fruits.
Ce sont des structures
formées par des parasites
appelées galle ou cécidie.
Les fruits du gaïac sont en fait
cette petite gousse en forme de spirale,
qui rappelle le nom latin de l'espèce,
acacia spirorbis.
J'ajouterais bien que
ses fleurs ne sont pas de fleurs,
mais je crois que vous avez
deviné l'arnaque.
Effectivement, ce ne sont pas des fleurs,
mais des groupements de petites fleurs,
des inflorescences.
Une inflorescence peut ressembler à ça,
une inflorescence complexe
comme une queue de renard,
ou alors, ça peut ressembler à ça,
une sorte d'ombrelle
qu'on appelle justement ombelle.
C'est une ombelle de carotte sauvage.
Regardez comme c'est bien rangé !
Une inflorescence peut
également ressembler à ça.
Oui,
les petites languettes qu'on voit
ne sont pas des pétales,
mais des fleurs individuelles.
Et au centre également,
c'est un agglomérat de petites fleurs.
En fait, sur cette image,
vous contemplez un bouquet
de 35 fleurs environ.
Maintenant qu'on a vu
un certain type de fleurs,
pourrez-vous répondre à la question :
de quelle couleur sont les fleurs
du bougainvillier ?
Allez-y, allez-y !
(Public) Blanche.
Oh, j'ai entendu la bonne réponse.
Au premier abord,
on aurait envie de répondre
rose, fuchsia, jaune,
que sais-je, mais ...
les fleurs du bougainvillier
sont invariablement blanches.
La partie colorée est formée
par ce qu'on appelle des bractées,
des parties de l'inflorescence
qui ressemblent à des feuilles
et qui sont positionnées
aux alentours de la fleur.
Donc, on a vu un arbre
qui n'a pas de feuilles visibles,
des fruits qui ne sont pas des fruits.
On a vu aussi
des fleurs qui sont
des groupements de fleurs,
quasiment des feuilles.
Mais les estomacs gourmands
me diront peut-être
que peu importe la fleur,
pourvu qu'on aie le miel.
Si je vous parlais maintenant d'un miel
que les abeilles arrivent à confectionner
à partir d'une plante
qui n'a pas de fleur.
Vous l'avez sans doute remarqué,
mais les sapins n'ont pas de fleurs.
Il y a pourtant du miel de sapin.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Il y a des petits insectes
comme des cochenilles ou des pucerons,
qui s'installent
sur les aiguilles du sapin
pour se nourrir de leur sève
et qui rejettent ensuite, par l'anus,
une déjection sucrée
que les abeilles viennent
ensuite récupérer
pour confectionner le miel de sapin.
Une étude scientifique,
très sérieuse,
a découvert qu'il s'agissait
du caca le plus délicieux de l'univers.
Je voudrais lever une ambiguïté :
je ne suis pas botaniste.
Je travaille dans l'informatique.
C'est justement en tant que non botaniste
que je m'adresse à vous.
Car pendant très longtemps,
les plantes n'étaient rien pour moi.
Plutôt, elles ne me parlaient que de moi,
mes préférences alimentaires, esthétiques,
olfactives,
éventuellement,
quelques souvenirs attachants,
une contrée familière.
J'ai commencé à apprendre
le nom de certaines plantes,
il y a environ trois ans,
à l'occasion de chantiers
de reboisement en milieu associatif.
C'était la première fois
que j'étais amenée à côtoyer de si près
des plantes qui ne me seraient
d'aucune utilité directe.
Et c'est peut-être bien ça
qui a laissé de l'espace à la curiosité.
Car j'ai découvert
que quand on commence
à apprendre sur les plantes,
on a envie d'en savoir toujours plus.
Ça donne à apprendre
dans de nombreux domaines :
La botanique évidemment,
mais aussi l'écologie, l'histoire,
la géologie, la nutrition, la latin.
On apprend sur les usages
traditionnels des plantes,
sur les pharmacopées.
On a envie de les dessiner.
Bref, c'est un régal pour l'esprit.
Il y a énormément
de choses bizarres à apprendre.
Saviez-vous que les cacahuètes
poussent sous terre ?
Que les figues ne sont pas
vraiment des fruits ?
Ou que cette insignifiante banane -
eh oui, une banane
peut en cacher une autre -
que cette insignifiante banane
a plus de gènes
que la personne qui
l'a bien rattrapée finalement (rit).
Donc, on a vu
qu'il est de notre responsabilité
de mieux connaître les plantes.
C'est une responsabilité joyeuse
qui va donner du sens à nos actions
et semer des petites graines
de bonheur dans notre vie.
C'est aussi quelque chose
qui va nous relier au monde,
si on l'avait perdu de vue.
Car en effet, quand on cultive son jardin,
on profite d'une certaine
qualité de solitude,
à la fois très simple et très agréable.
Pourtant, faire son jardin,
c'est participer à un grand tout,
c'est créer avec les autres.
Les pollens se diffusent.
Les graines s'accrochent aux vêtements.
Un jardin n'est jamais totalement isolé
du reste du monde.
Et cela vaut aussi pour les terrasses
et les coins de fenêtres.
Tout ce que vous planterez dans votre vie,
même si ce ne sont que
quelques pots de fleurs sur le balcon,
vous survivra d'une manière ou d'une autre
et se propagera à la manière d'un message.
Alors, à vous de voir
quel est le message que
vous souhaitez envoyer au monde futur ?
Voulez-vous que votre jardin soit
votre collection d'espèces introduites,
potentiellement envahissantes ?
Ou bien un écosystème à part entière
qui nourrisse vos proches dans le respect
de la nature environnante ?
Ou encore, un sanctuaire
d'espèces menacées ?
Eh oui, vous pouvez
en trouver en pépinière.
Le lieux où on s'approvisionne en plantes
sont comme des dictionnaires.
À vous d'y piocher les mots
qui vous survivront.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)